[Music]
what's going on guys
state of the furious it's hitting
theaters and you know the fashion of
Furious franchise it's all about family
so what's the best thing to do other
than tear that family apart and rank
them and we have some fast and furious
individuals on this panel to do that for
us
first oh she's a friend of screen
junkies you know from SJ news and FX
movie download Sasha pearl raver I am so
excited I live to talk about this
gentleman you've seen him on screen
junkies news movie fights he's the
co-host of the trusty sidekick podcast
and a very funny stand-up comedian
welcome to the show Jay Washington thank
you thank you and finally you know him
you love him he's all over screen
junkies you know I'm from schmoes know
and his YouTube channel jte movie thinks
jte I'm happy to be your house we gave
you a list of Fast & Furious franchise
characters to rank we took your rankings
we average them together and we came up
with the master list the top dozen the
Dirty Dozen of fast and furious
characters here we go at the bottom
bringing up the rear at number 12 gal
gadot Giselle oh dude so she was one
above my last honestly I was worried
about Wonder Woman because I thought gal
gadot was so terrible in the Fast and
Furious franchise and also there's a
moment in five where she's like I'm
gonna go seduce this guy and she's in a
bathing suit and she supposed to look
all sexy and there she's been taking the
no acetal pills
there was just no but and anybody who
loves the fastened areas know it is all
about you buying up those of GMC
nutrition has made their name on hunter
but I want to go to jte who had you had
Gisele gal gadot hiya so they're headed
towards the middle I didn't put the
button to the decision-making here I'm
sorry that's always what's up by
education making Bobby Bass appear but I
do think she was a cool character and
she had some memorable scenes and I
thought the relationship with her de
Haan actually added to the franchise you
liked her but they did
and she's number 12 bringing up the rear
number 11 on the list Jordana Brewster
Mia Toretto
Marc's Network I played for Mia today
right yeah I put me a little bit higher
more only like two three spots higher
she's kind of secondary character who's
there to give really whole Walker's
character just more motivation and
background like she's there to help that
character be a better character Walker
now has a family when it comes to
Jordana Brewster character they have a
child together
yeah but to support and his character or
she I don't feel like she ever gets a
moment in any of these films to really
shine like what's the Jordana Brewster
moment for you exactly okay the first
movie they really just made her an
exposition yes yeah all right
number 10 Sean Boswell Lucas black the
fact is this guy was the star of his own
movie he was a star of one of the
fastest movies and still not that
memorable well to me that really broke
him down to really low my list I feel
like Lucas black really fell victim to
people hating Tokyo Drift yeah because
it went so outside of what we going to
expect and I honestly feel like there's
characters that were much worse and he
just got sort of subjugated well Lucas
black coming in at number 10 let's go to
number 9 Sung Kang Han I think I have
all day you're the highest on a
letterman number seven because he was
Dominic Toretto's day one over again we
talked about family and friends he's no
Toretto the longest yeah he's been a
friend the longest he was always there
and that's what this whole franchise is
predicated on yeah you have the core of
the family you have the Cerreto Letty
Brian Mia you have the core yet Mia
number 11 yeah they're not getting a lot
of love JT I don't hear a big action fan
Han has gotten in some like awesome
action moments I think he's cool you
mention he has this history Dom we don't
really get to know about that it's
literally one line a movie like I've
known him since oh it's oh yeah that's
all you get about the history between
those two there's not much there a
second oh yeah always always waiting
like a STONER and using snacks all times
and maybe a little more alright moving
on number eight on our list
Owen Shaw portrayed by Lucy Evan
I never much lower and had a much lower
you had him laugh last okay talk on
laughing there's very rarely been a good
build in a somes
too fast too furious the first fast and
furious all games I have a four out of
em who the villain wasn't some drug lord
he was the first time to show us there
could be a decent villain but there's
nothing about him in fact he got
upstaged by his brother but because of
who he was him being central abroad to
his cartel and everything pulling in
Letty after she had amnesia that made
him rank higher to me that was a solid
villain I'm a villain fan in movies oh
yeah I am a big villain fan and that's
what he didn't go higher in my ranking
alright let's move on to number seven
Tyrese Gibson Roman Pearce alright
you let out of a big side air cuz I was
last on my list Wow I'm not as high Rhys
man I am NOT
if special especially comes to acting he
is the same character in every single
movie there's nothing unique about that
character he just talks a lot he runs
his mouth I could have been that
character but I can't fit in the cars
besides talking besides running his
mouth what else does one appears didn't
I think a lot he's the audience a lot of
times he's the guy going what the f are
we about to do I'm more like Tyrese than
anybody on that team oh yeah we do it
we're about to do this are you all crazy
like he's that kind of Racer point J see
he's calling out all regal stuff yeah
moving on coming at number six Luda hey
Parker
talk to me about Luda you guys there's
only going to be a tech guy yeah that is
true one of the things that makes these
songs so incredible is that they're
super multicultural yeah so when you've
got ramsey Natalie Manuel from Game of
Thrones and you got tej Ludacris playing
the computer geniuses that's a great
representation that I'm really excited
to see on screen and sometimes when we
see a guy it's normally the older have
you said no it's a white day this is
chunky white dude who's like my mom
doesn't know I be number 5 Jason Statham
Deckard Shaw so you had that Deckard
Shaw at number 5 so you nailed that a
man's ribbon over fringe wanted to stick
up for his little his younger brother
man who was I'm gonna get who get this
to my brother I'm going after Toretto
and everybody the introduction of Jason
Statham where he comes out about
hospital yeah you see just every
destroyed and you know you are dealing
with an unmitigated badass Oh at the
back I totally agree I haven't liked
round number seven and reason why I
didn't wear lowest on it only because
screen time he's the fire for the first
villain I was like okay we have a villa
on this ranch at me and I'm real care to
see what they do with apart eight but
the orders why I put them a little bit
lower on my list is because I had to
give to the other guys I've just seen
them more they've been around more they
have more storylines alright we've
reached the final four you guys coming
in at number four Dwayne the rock
Johnson Hobbs the man who some say
revitalized this franchise Jay you had
this man at number two you talked to me
how does that you bring somebody in
who's as charismatic and his
action-packed and who can integrate with
all these characters as well as a rock
did you put them in there and the
blending of them to deal with each
personality it's a different interaction
but it's the same interaction mm-hmm
he'll interact with Toretto one way but
then interact with a Roman Pearce a
different way then interact with the
Deckard Shaw a different way that's a
great point because the Missal franchise
i've been around for four movies he
jumps right in and it's like oh yeah
where you been all my life
yeah you know the rock really did for me
five is probably after one the best of
the faster Darius movies and it's
largely because of what the rock did
Sasha I think he summed it up when you
said the rock makes everything better
all right move it on number three this
I'm personally surprised by this and you
can't say three is low but coming in at
number three Dominic Toretto
then yes it's a breakdown okay
I want to talk to mr. Jay Washington cuz
you a Dominic Toretto the lowest of
anyone I can't blame the president oh
hello England's pandemonium on the set
so Jay you had this man Vin Diesel
Dominic Toretto at number four why what
difference have we seen in Dominic
Toretto from dae-jung me in every single
act is a perfect he is the same person
in every yeah - ain't you only had a
bonus
Oh Jane you had him at number three
yes he's just the same thing in every
movie there's no character development
almost he loses people he gets people
back and either way he just kind of
grunts but I'm good oh you're bad
Sasha I'm having so many feelings right
now I know I you guys can talk about
family DOM is the family he's the one
who owns the barbecue he's the reason
Joyce has caused Asha to have an episode
she felt like all of the valley girl oh
my god it's a period you can try all of
it you're getting water feeling dry yeah
well you got to handle it because coming
in at number two always guy I wake you
Michelle Rodriguez high or team although
you screwed that up for you later
Lenny was my number one her and Hobbes
are the top two badass that keep this
franchise alive and going yes you need a
Vin Diesel if he was to die could this
franchise continue yes
rocking step right in yes probably just
good mom but what happens with Lenny who
wasn't even in the best one when they
resurrected that far that's a big boy ah
number five is widely considered the
best one in the five after credit scene
is oh no but you see after credit
sequence
let's just get in everyone doesn't see
you my happy all right you may know it
already but the number one Fast and
Furious character of all time Brian
O'Connor Paul Walker
r.i.p J controversial choice here it is
you had Brian O'Connor Paul Walker at
number six it Wow we're at home again
now what's going on I mean are you guys
watching the same guy outside what
number one you had about number one I
mean number six
wow I don't appreciate this hostility I
like it who is a lovely uses
I love what he brings to this franchise
but when you're talking about what this
franchise becomes and what it grows into
he goes down that list
again that's how you get a hops going up
that's how you get a Deckard Shaw but
that's how you get these people going up
he has to go down I get it it's Paul
Walker he started this thing but you're
talking about a revitalization of a
franchise that a lot of people wrote off
for a while yeah he drops down that is
my story and I'm sticking to it before I
run you make an excellent point Jay in
that the franchise was starting to dip
and then they brought in these
characters that revitalize that's what
added some excitement that's what had a
jump start to it so lay it down
why is Brian O'Conner number one yeah I
got I just love where his story starts
in the ends and we do literally it's the
hope yes fast versus when we go to a
point break he's a cop
who goes against being a contact even
when he comes back and part four and
still in the agency then he finally
becomes the villain but I mean to the
police goes on the run with DOM and I
know for me just like his story is the
most interesting if you look at all the
characters throughout like our Vin
Diesel's character is just out lungs
grumpy that's this whole thing about
this whole franchise again I understand
you need Dom with him because they're
great together little two together is
what made this franchise over for me he
just kind of completes everything that
this ranch has been through and he
worked both sides and it's Paul Walker
he's great yeah Sasha thought he was
always the character that had the most
to lose because it did work for the FBI
he had the highest stakes he always had
the most approved he had the most to
lose
he created the family with me and Dom
the number one and the number two that
are the tip of the pyramid of this
franchise
I just reached I did not realize that
this list would tear our family apart
but we did it we came up with our top 12
they are ranked what did you think of
those rankings what would you rank
higher what would you rank lower and
what's your favorite fast moment of all
times let us know in the comments
section below we want to know
I got a thank this panel for really
going there you guys got emotional there
were ups downs
Sasha Pearl raver thank you so much Jay
Washington thank you sir jte
there
great to have you on the show and thank
you for watching I'm how Rudnick's hit
me up on Twitter bye-bye
hey guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show
honest trailers movie fights and more